so don't complain about the sound
quality don't complain about there's no
video just
[ __ ] let it be
enjoy life
it's a real i feel like the last four
years we've all been on drugs
trump is a drug for the people that love
him
and for the people that hate him he's
been a drug
everybody's been hopped up on trump
the media hollywood
his supporters everybody
and now the party's over
and people are still acting
like the party's still going on like you
know when you used to get [ __ ] up with
people in high school
and they pretended they were more drunk
than they were
and you knew that they weren't that
[ __ ] up or when you would trip
out with somebody and they clearly had
come down and they're like i'm still up
there man and it's like no you're not
get us in the car and drive us somewhere
you're fine
that's what trump supporters hardcore
trump supporters
are acting like right now they're
pretending they're still drunk
at a party in high school they're like
dude i'm [ __ ] up
dude we're gonna win we're gonna win bro
[ __ ] georgia dude i'm so
[ __ ] wrecked right now bro are you
right it's like you're not wrecked
we know you're not wrecked you're not
drunk anymore
you're not even drunk you barely had
anything to drink
we saw you you're barely
barely drunk you can legally drive you
just pretended to fall down you can
legally drive
and that's where we are right now in
this great land
we have people and then there's people
even on the other side like they're like
he'll
never go away he'll never leave
it's like this shit's all going to end
dude covent is going to
end trump is going to end and you
have to accept the reality where those
things are not running your life anymore
and i know that's depressing to many of
you because
even though you might have loved or
hated trump he was this sense of
stability you're gonna wake up
the president was gonna tweet something
[ __ ] up
and then there was this plague outside
that prevented you from doing anything
those things are gonna come to an end
we're at dinner the other night and
people are like
trump's gonna have this big media empire
and i'm like
i'm going on record now and i could be
wrong
but i'm going record on record right now
i don't think he will
i don't think trump's gonna have a
massive media empire
it takes a ton of capital can you give
me a bottle of water from that
thank you i'm sorry i don't want to make
you breathe in the [ __ ]
ben's very sensitive i spent 10 years
doing cocaine so i can't really
smell a ton but ben's very like i can't
i can't understand why they would do
this with the chemicals
and i know i don't understand it either
they were doing a deep covert clean
because apparently they thought this was
a [ __ ] hospital
this house is cleaner than a hospital
right now
this is cleaner than the er ben the
bottle of water is right there on the
bar
you don't need to get just get the
bottle of water on the bar please
and bring it out here i called the guy
who sent the maids i'm like dude what
the [ __ ]
i like this guy too
but he sent this husband a wife couple
and they're a real [ __ ] problem
the regular maid it's her birthday so
she went away for the weekend
what was i saying before that trump this
he's not going to start a media empire
well i mean he might try
you need a lot of capital to start a
media empire people don't seem to
realize that you need tons and tons of
capital
right and i just don't think
he's going to do it i could be wrong
i might be wrong i just don't know he's
going to start a media empire
people seemed very upset last night when
i kind of were telling him like this is
ending the movie is ending
they were like no no he's crazy he's not
going away
one of the guys at the table goes he's
not going away
he's gonna have a media empire he's
gonna be bigger than ever i'm like are
you children
this is like people in high school
before they go to college going
dude we're still going to be best buds
forever you're not
you're probably not maybe
statistically you're not some guy you
know some guy says his girlfriend is
like
even though we're going to different
schools we're still going to [ __ ]
love each it's you're not it's over
have a few summer [ __ ] and those are
the tweets he's tweeting out right now
that's a few summer [ __ ] because it's
ending
things end and i think that this has
been such a
visceral experience for so many people
it has been really really impactful and
they
their entire sense of reality is wrapped
around
this guy and people's reaction to this
guy
that the idea of there not being a
donald trump
or it not being like this huge fight
every minute of every day the drama the
excitement
people are this is like drug addicts
coming down
we're coming down we're being weaned off
a drug that we've all been on for four
years
and somebody goes to dinner last night
to go he's gonna run again in four years
are you people nuts
how bad do you need this guy the oxygen
trump takes all the oxygen out of the
room
he's gonna run again he's gonna have a
media empire and then he's gonna run
again
he's not going anywhere yeah he's going
to go somewhere he's going to die
eventually
when you're going to handle that then
somebody at the table goes i think
ivanka will run
there's just no thought that this is
coming to an end
same thing with coven it's coming to an
end folks
not tomorrow not soon but eventually
it's gonna come
to an end we're going to get a vaccine
or there's going to be herd immunity
and we're going to move on and i know
that that's tariff people are like
terrified of moving on
from these two situations you talk to
people they don't like they don't even
like to hear that when i go colvin's
it's gonna end they're going oh i don't
know about that
i'm like do you not want to end are you
invested in this being the reality
forever
oh i don't think it'll end well i don't
think so
people go people are going to wear masks
forever nothing will ever go back to
normal
no one will ever leave their house again
this is just the way it [ __ ] is
i'm like well in many states they're
leaving their house now
no this won't end trump's gonna have a
media empire
we'll live in this reality forever and
i'm like it's
it's i've been to rehab i've sobered up
off drugs
if this is very similar to addict
behavior in in
early sobriety early sobriety
is all about the idea that
you're learning to let go of the things
and the people that you had built this
life around as a drug addict needing
this drug the rituals
the the people the places the things all
of that
have to change early sobriety later on
you get deeper into why you're a [ __ ]
addict and you go [ __ ] me
i should go to a therapist i gotta deal
with [ __ ] right
but early sobriety is all about like
okay i can't hang out with
bill anymore because he's a problem
so we're an early sobriety right now a
lot of people are sobering up
q and honest it's a real rough time now
i just hired a personal trainer i'm
trying to get him in the q a on right
now
just to get him down a rabbit hole so it
doesn't [ __ ] bother me
but i just hired a trainer i've been
told to hire a trainer forever
and i just hired a [ __ ] trainer and i
started trying to get him in the queue
on the low i started texting him i'm
like hey man have you heard about this
he's like yeah i've been hearing
something about that i'm like why don't
you start reading about that
he's like so what'd you eat today i'm
like why don't we talk a little bit
about q and on
for a minute let's just let's just say
there's bigger problems than what i had
for breakfast
let's just try to let's just try to
solve a few riddles that were posted
on the internet sir just before we get
to the training session
let's talk a little bit about cue
but the queuing on people i mean it's
going they're going to sober up
like a cult it's a few years ago like
yeah man i was a
people you know they're gonna do netflix
documentaries like you know leah remini
is
talking about scientology there's and by
the way is that even interesting there's
like 25 documentaries
about people that used to be in
scientology who gives a [ __ ]
yeah you thought you were an alien and
made 10 million dollars why do we have
to hear about it forever
are you people heroes i don't even
understand i mean didn't you torture
children too
what are you talking about why am i even
interested in this it's clearly a cult
we all knew it was a cult
we all thought you were [ __ ] when
you were talking about xenu
and an explosion of souls and that this
is how you
and auditing it was clearly a blackmail
operation you tell
all your secrets to a guy that records
them and then you can't get out
it's blackmail we know what it is it's
epstein's island we get it everyone else
gets it
why is there 35 documentaries about this
this is like explaining santa claus not
being real
yeah we know that nobody's shocked about
that
everyone's like oh this is this uh have
you seen have you read going claire have
you seen going clear
it's amazing it's all the scientology
get wrapped up into this call yet it's a
cult like anything else like anything
else
it's not that interesting it's only
interesting
because celebrities are in it let's be
very clear
no one would give a [ __ ] about
scientology if it was
poor people only and a lot of them are
broke
but if tom cruise wasn't in it would no
one would give a [ __ ]
they'd be like oh yeah those people
believe that uh you know they're all
alien life forms that were uh yeah yeah
they're into that
but because like tom cruise is in it
everybody's like wow this is
uh it's pretty cool
but it's secure they're gonna have q and
on docs is my point
in a few years there's gonna be somebody
talking about that they weren't queuing
on they were like well i was a follower
of q
for years and then i finally realized
that when my husband kidnapped my son
because i thought he thought i was
selling him the clintons
and he kidnapped my son and he drove him
across state lines
i realized the error of my ways i
realized that i shouldn't have been just
reading those q
drops every day i should have been
looking for work
it's going to be queuing on docs